Google cloud next 2017 hosted a
veritable buffet of talks detailing the
future of cloud if you didn't get a
chance to catch the session Google Cloud
Storage best practices then stay tuned
because here is the recap Google Cloud
Storage offers a great set of features
for writing storing and distributing
content for whatever application you're
building when you're considering
performance for your GCS use case most
people only consider whether they should
set up the bucket to be regional
multi-regional Nearline or cold storage
but there's a few more things to
consider if you'd like to really
maximize your performance in general GCS
is really strong in terms of single
stream throughput however there's
typically a fixed latency cost per
request so obviously for the best
performance you should really favored
larger requests in order to optimize
your throughput but this isn't always an
option
sometimes you're just stuck with small
objects in which case getting the best
performance means paralyzing your
requests so there's overlap fixed
latency costs and avoiding resumable
requests since the overhead of round
trips on lots of small objects can add
up to be a significant problem now when
serving data you generally have the
choice of regional or multi regional
buckets regional is really good for
compute scenarios because you typically
want your VMs close to your data source
to maximize throughput and you don't
want the overhead of bookkeeping that's
needed for multi regional redundancy
you'll see higher throughput in this
case multi-regional on the other hand is
great for serving contents it's it can
achieve great remote latency due to
usage of CD ends where Google will
automatically push assets to the edges
of its network based upon usage patterns
without you having to do any heavy
lifting now writing data to GCS is a
completely different problem most people
run writing to a GCS bucket quickly find
that they hit a wall or ceiling a
basically a point way in which things
don't get any faster when we see this we
generally find that the developers are
writing sequential file names to their
GCS buckets
the reason this causes a performance
problem has to do with how GCS shards
and load balances your write request
internally so that they scale
when you've got sequential names the
balancer can't properly segment and move
things around as efficiently hence the
bottlenecks now to address this firstly
try to submit buckets of work in
parallel for example the foo and bar
folders can be uploaded in parallel
without stomping all over each other
secondly consider prepend ahah shove the
file name to the file name itself which
given the distributed nature of your
hashing algorithm will create a
nonlinear distribution a file name is
resulting in better load balancing if
you'd like some more details on these
GCSE performance optimizations as well
as a cool demo on using a Hadoop with
GCS check out the full next video and if
you want more recaps on great next
content make sure to check out the rest
of our playlist
[Music]